why does that bearded fellow who plays
charles goodnight on 1883 look like
someone we've seen before and what does
he have to do with the show behind the
scenes keep watching for the answer even
people only vaguely aware of shows like
yellowstone in 1883 probably know taylor
sheridan has something to do with the
massively successful franchise at the
heart of the paramount network and he
does he's a creator yellowstone the
first tv series sheridan has created is
an enduring hit spawning multiple
spin-offs including 1883 a series that
tells the story of the first duttons in
montana four sixes an upcoming series
set at the real life four sixes ranch in
texas and 1932 about the dutton's
difficulties during the great depression
sheridan is also the creator of mayor of
kingstown a paramount plus series
starring jeremy renner and a slew of
other upcoming originals including tulsa
king starring sylvester stallone lioness
starring zoe saldana landman starring
billy bob thornton and bass reeves
starring david oyelowo while sheridan is
arguably best known for his
behind-the-scenes work on these series
his career in hollywood goes back much
further than the launch of yellowstone
in 2018. before sheridan made a name for
himself as a writer he primarily worked
as an actor and he's been in some pretty
recognizable roles in recent years
sheridan is focused on writing but he's
also made a handful of appearances on
his own projects including a brief role
in 2016's hell or high water and an
appearance in 1883 is charles goodnight
a real historical figure when you bought
off more than you can chew you sure
about big well before he led the
yellowstone franchise sheridan appeared
as deputy chief david hale on a total of
21 episodes of fx's hit series sons of
anarchy he was an integral part of the
early series appearing in all but four
episodes of the first two seasons
throughout the first season hale
operates as one of the last honest
officers in charming hale hates samcro's
criminal enterprise so he initially
pursues the group in a fashion decidedly
different from that of his fellow law
enforcement officers most of whom have
essentially learned to live with the
biker gains actions you make a deal with
the devil to keep the peace
but look at this
look at what we let happen in season two
hale begins to see the wisdom in working
with the group and opts to form an
alliance of sorts with charlie hunnam's
jax teller sadly their alliance is
relatively short-lived in the season
three premiere hale is killed in a
drive-by shooting at a funeral in the
years since his exit from the acclaimed
fx series sheridan has spoken rather
bluntly about his decision to leave the
show in a wide-ranging interview with
deadline in 2021 sharon admitted that he
was troubled with a number of things on
sons of anarchy including his pay
however even more troubling to sheridan
was the way that he was viewed as a
lower level team member on the
production he said it wasn't so much
over money it was so much more that
that's how the business saw me
sheridan's departure motivated him to
pick up writing again which would lead
to big things sheridan isn't exactly shy
about including himself as an on-screen
presence in the series that he leads
sheridan made his first appearance on
yellowstone in season 1's coming home as
travis wheatley a role which he has
reprised a number of times since horse
trader travis is a through-and-through
cowboy known for his no-nonsense
attitude and expert writing abilities
while sheridan only appeared in a single
episode of season one he returned his
travis for two more episodes in season
two he opted to sit out season three but
made up for his lack of screen time by
appearing in five different episodes
during season four as a favor to kevin
costner's john dutton travis gives
jefferson white's jimmy hudstrom a ride
to the four sixes ranch in texas the
cowboys home state and that's all
cowboying is
all right it's you and a horse doing a
job trying like hell to not let the
other down we think it's safe to say
that travis will probably find another
reason to visit montana and yellowstone
season 5 too and while not much is known
about the 46's spin-off yet it also
seems like a safe bet than any
yellowstone series is bound to feature
sheridan in some role
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]